I roam the Web never leaving a trace, Prying and snooping, I feel no disgrace.
No cookies or IP's can give me away, I go where I please, then enjoy my stay.
Your e-mail or domain, I will uncover The more you conceal, the more I discover.
Something to hide and prefer not to share?
Too bad? I'll find it, so liars beware!!
Wicked and naughty describes me the best,...
...When my sleuthing talents are put to the test.
I lurk uninvited, seeking to scare,...
...Come search me out, that's if you dare!
"Why won't she leave me alone?" you whine,...
...I want some privacy while I'm online.
Once you thought I was funny and smart,...
...Now you're sure I'm a bitch with no heart!
Has she the ability to invade my real life?
Her skill to intrude causing panic and strife.
You eye the shadows with fear and dread,...
...Hiding from a woman who's one step ahead.
But you and I won't meet face to face,...
...I prowl only the corridors of cyberspace.
You smile again; I can see you're relieved,...
But can a cyber - stalker ever be believed?
I hold my computer in the highest esteem,...
...Because in this world, I'm stalker supreme.
And one thing's for certain, come what may,...
The art of cyberstalking is here to stay!!